you grew up coming to Universal Studios  and now you work at Universal Studios  that's kind of trippy it's such a trip  yeah I grew up in LA and you know as a  kid we'd come and ride the tram and it  was just magic it was just like oh my  god one day maybe I'll get to you know  make movies or make TV and now every day  about a hundred times a day the tram  goes right by my trailer and go starring  America Ferrera the first time in the  day I'm like Welling up and remembering  being a kid and by the hundreds I'm in  the day I'm like oh my god are you here  by day yeah it's like really cool a  novel difference then you're like cool  it's starting I will not stop talking  until you subscribe to my YouTube  channel that's right and I could talk a  lot seriously not gonna stop yep still  here not going anywhere I see you don't  walk away from this